et
avec vous pour en parler général
dominique trinquant expert en
géostratégie un conseiller défense
emmanuel macron pendant la campagne
présidentielle de 2017 bonsoir général
merci d'être avec nous à nos côtés
également emmanuel leroy président de
l'institut 17 17 pour une nouvelle
alliance franco russe bonsoy emmanuel
leroy merci de nous accompagner en skype
également claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales et nous
rejoindra un petit peu plus tard un an
dans ce débat olivier bur lot qui lui
nous donne un petit peu le sentiment des
français à moscou un puisque olivier bur
lot vous êtes président du conseil
consulaires russie biélorussie à tout à
l'heure donc ça fait quoi maintenant
quatre heures à peu près que ça dure
général le train quand quatre heures de
discussions on s'attendait à des
discussions longues à le kremlin avait
dit l'elysée aussi ça prendra le temps
qu'il faudra oui ça prendra le temps de
sous la forme d'un face à face que le
président macron affectionne de se
retrouver face à on l'a vu dans la
petite séance qui était filmé au départ
où les deux hommes se connaissent bien
je pense qu'ils s'apprécient et le
président poutine l'a dit d'ailleurs un
finalité plus tôt alors car plutôt
chaleureuse et en plus dans le contexte
dans lequel on et souvenons nous qu'il y
a quinze jours à peu près le président
poutine se retrouver face au président
bailon on se retrouver dans la situation
près années 90 russie
etats-unis on ne parlait pas des
européens au même moment le président
macron intervenait au parlement français
pardon au parlement européen en parlant
de du format normandie et du fait que
l'europe devait y être relié en tant que
président français pas qu en tant que
président européen mais ceci étant il
joue un peu les précurseurs il a appelé
tous les européens tous les européens
qui un à un à mon avis doivent lui dire
qu'il faut négocier alors qu'autour de
la table c'est plus compliqué donc je
crois qu'il est dans une position
intéressante j'ai entendu parler de
persévérance donc je n'échappe pas au
plaisir de vous citer le le prince
d'orange qui disait qu'il n'était pas
nécessaire
d'espérer pour entreprendre et de
réussir pour persévérer et bien le
président macron persévère et je pense
qu'il a raison je pense pas qu'il ya un
résultat une fumée blanche qui va sortir
à la fin mais au moins la voie de la
diplomatie est tracé claude blanche
maison quand vous avez vu ces deux
hommes s'installer le long de cet
immense table c'est vrai que l'image
était assez cocasse
il y a une forme de chaleur peut-être
qui se dégage est en tout cas de respect
ça augure peut-être de de bonnes
discussions franches et viriles mais
dans le respect ce sont d'ailleurs deux
hommes qui se respecte ans on peut dire
ça sans se tromper
ou sur la liste en physique eux
n'avaient pas d'autre signification que
le sanitaire est en réalité les deux
hommes se connaissent bien et je crois
s'apprécient je crois d'ailleurs que
le préfet de route il a été assez facile
et par l' aventure électorale du
président macron il est à 50 cas que
d'un personnage aussi jeunes sans aucun
parti politique puisse gagner les
élections présidentielles françaises et
ils ont eu l'occasion de discuter à
beaucoup de reprises alors monsieur
mâcon vient avec plusieurs casquettes
comme ça a déjà été dit il est en effet
le prétend la république française bien
sûr - la république française qui est
membre du conseil de sécurité mais il
est aussi un des protagonistes d'une
forme à normandie et ceci il le partage
avec le président poutine et le
chancelier allemand et puis il est aussi
répondre à quelques mois le président du
conseil de l'union européenne et à ce
titre et il a des choses à dire alors
bien entendu il n'a pas de mandat précis
des européens mais après tout il peut
faire une mission exploratoire et voir
quelles seraient les thermes au qui
permettrait de progresser dans la
désescalade avec le président macron y
compris sur des sujets qui sont les
sujets de sécurité et même si l'union
européenne n'a pas de véritables
compétences en matière de sécurité
puisqu'elle n'a pas d'armé elle a un
poids considérable en matière économique
et là aussi les propositions peuvent
peut-être être évoquée emmanuel leroy
vous l'ami de la russie 1 vous vous
prenez en tout cas ce rapprochement vous
avez de grands espoirs ce soir en tout
cas c'est une bonne chose que ces deux
hommes se rencontrent bien toute façon
les contacts sont toujours préférables à
l'affrontement bien évidemment donc mais
pour ma part et au risque de jouer les
rabat joie je vous avouerai que je
n'attends pas grand chose de cette
rencontre que j'assimile beaucoup plus
apte delà des postures de type
diplomatique ou politique mais je ne
crois pas qu'ils n'en sortira grand
chose d'abord pour la première raison
c'est que les russes se sont adressés
non pas à la france et ni non plus à
l'union européenne mais aux états unis
et à l'otan ce sont eux les
interlocuteurs se sont eux qui ont reçu
les lettres leur demandant de clarifier
la position de l'otan à l'égard de la
russie la france et la glace
on sait grâce et l'union européenne non
plus n'ont pas été conviés à ce discours
comme si elles n'étaient pas considérés
comme des interlocuteurs valables
toutefois le kremlin a jugé
l'interlocuteur intéressant jeu kremlin
et
il ne pourrait pas jouer un rôle de
médiateur finalement emmanuel macron
dans cette affaire c'est exactement le
jaune rôle qu'il veut jouer dans le rôle
de puissance d'être libre d'essayer de
jouer un rôle après et je suis d'accord
au départ le président poutine a voulu
discuter avec le président maiden et il
a eu le tort à mon avis de présenter une
position écrite dont il savait que la
réponse très négative et donc pour se
sortir de ce guêpier si j'ose dire
maintenant faut trouver d'autres moyens
et c'est là que le président en nacre on
peut essayer de son de jouer ce rôle je
suis assez d'accord je disais que la
fumée blanche ne sortira pas ce soir
c'est probable mais ceci étant
oui mais ceci étant demain il sera à
kiev parce que la partie de cafard son
rôle à jouer aussi un rappel que
l'accord de minsk s'est pas uniquement
la partie russe qui doit faire quelque
chose de la partie ukrainienne doit
bouger
sont aujourd'hui dans les mains de deux
hélène ce qui est exactement donc c'est
le rôle qui va qui va jouer devant
demain je pense que au delà de la crise
ukrainienne bien au delà ya le problème
de la sécurité en europe qui est que le
président poutine a mis sur la table et
là il ya des choses qui ont été oubliés
depuis des années parce qu'on pensait
que c'était évident mais les mesures de
confiance qu'on appelait les mesures de
confiance ont été totalement abandonnée
et il faut les remettre sur la table et
là je pense que il faut élever le débat
et profiter de cette situation pour
essayer de pacifier les rapports j'ose
dire encore entre l'est et l'ouest mais
qui devrait plus être des rapports de ce
type tout ceci ce sont des pays
européens et qui est je suis heureux que
ce soit un président d'un pays européen
qui traite de problèmes européens et non
pas uniquement les états unis avec la
russie sur cette confiance justement je
voudrais vous faire
écoutez ce passage important hier dans
le journal du dimanche à emmanuel macron
qui parle justement du point de vue
russe
nous devons donc protéger nos frères
européens en proposant un nouvel
équilibre capable de leur préserver la
souveraineté et la paix il faut le faire
en même temps dans le respect de la
russie et en comprenant les propres
traumatismes contemporain de ce grand
peuple et de cette grande nation j'ai
toujours été dans un dialogue profond
avec le président poutine est notre
responsabilité de bâtir des solutions
historiques il y a je crois une
disponibilité du président poutine pour
cela emmanuel leroy ça s'éteint un
passage certainement important emmanuel
macron qui parle aussi du besoin
légitime de la sécurité de la russie en
a on n'a peut-être pas toujours assez
parlé dans ce dossier ce qu'on sait pas
ce qu attend aujourd'hui la russie en
compte c'est la question clé et je
voudrais dire on en préalable que la
raison de cette crise ce n'est pas
l'armée russe aux frontières de
l'ukraine c'est l'armée ukrainienne dont
la moitié des effectifs sont basés sur
les frontières du donbass depuis
maintenant près d'un an et qui menace
d'attaquer à tout moment donc le
véritable danger il est là et ce que je
voudrais dire sur cette cave sur cette
affaire c'est que la france
effectivement un rôle clé à jouer dans
la résolution de cette crise avec la
l'application des accords de minsk je
rappelle effectivement que la france
comme l'allemagne et la russie sont les
garants d application de ces accords qui
n'ont jamais étaient ce qu'on dirait se
satisfait par par kiev j'avais encore ce
matin des contacts avec des amis
présents dans le donne pas ce qu'ils
font et encore ce matin le bombardement
de l'armée ukrainienne sur des
populations civiles et ça ce n'est
jamais dit dans la presse occidentale
que ce soit donc aux états unis ou en
europe c'est un point important ces
accords de minsk doivent être réglés et
le président macron demain à kiev je
l'espère
abordera cette question de manière
précise avec le président hélène ce qui
de manière à ce que ces accords soient
enfin respectés à vendre votre vernis et
bernad pas avoir un petit peu le
sentiment des français sur place sont
blanches maison sur ces accords de demi
que c'est l'une des pistes évidemment et
c'est l'une des clés de ce qui est en
train de se tramer entre venir poutine
emmanuel macron
je crois qu'on a perdu claude danse
raison vous nous entendez oui bah oui je
vous entends j'ai dit et je pense que
c'est l'une des pistes en effet et pour
emmanuel macron puisqu'il a toujours
marqué la plus grande importance au rôle
que la france et l'allemagne et la
russie devaient jouer dans les accords
de minsk est en effet il faut appliquer
les accords de mise que je suis tout à
fait d'accord sur le fait qu'il faut
inciter le président ukrainien appliquer
les accords de minsk évidemment le
président ukrainien ça n'est pas très
simple parce qu'il a aussi un parlement
et que dans son parlement il ya des
forces qui sont hostiles à l'application
de certaines dispositions
donc comme dans tout pays il faut tenir
compte des différentes forces en
présence alors je crois que en effet le
président de la république aussi
aujourd'hui a sans doute plus rassuré
son interlocuteur en rappelant que la
france comme d'ailleurs l'allemagne
avait indiqué en 2008 qu'elle était tout
à fait hostile à l'entrée de l'ukraine
et de la géorgie dans l'otan et qui a
pas de raison que cette position est
changée d'autant plus que ces pays sont
des pays divisé et que l'otan
n'acceptera pas qu'ils importent à
l'intérieur de l'organisation le conflit
le conflit interne donc je pense que
ceci fait beaucoup avancer les choses et
que on a un système de négociation qui
est enfin de se diversifier il y à une
négociation avec les américains qui la
négociation sur les questions
stratégiques
mais il ya une négociation dans le car
normandie qui a été heureux revigoré par
la réunion d'il ya une dizaine de jours
qui va continuer à berlin le 10 février
et puis il y a les autres questions sur
lesquelles le président mac ont
certainement va revenir avec une unité
précise de ce que veut le président
poutine en matière d'assurance de
sécurité pour la sécurité de la russie
et là c'est probablement l'objet de
toutes ces heures de discussions l'une
des lignes auront jour le sait ont
évidemment la répéter a lancé c'est
l'adhésion de l'ukraine à l'otan est ce
que la finlandisation comme on dit 'de
de l'ukraine est ce que ça va être là
aussi l'une des clés est peut-être l'une
des solutions qui peut être abordée
j'entends sida il ya deux façons de
sortir de cette crise pour l'ukraine en
tout cas la première serait non pas la
finlandisation mais
l'adoption d'une neutralité réel comme
celles comme celle de l'autriche ou la
suisse c'est la première façon que
l'ukraine aurait donc de sortir de sa
crise insoluble et la seconde se serait
donc de laisser des populations
russophones et russophiles de l'ukraine
rejoindre librement la russie ce serait
à mon avis des deux façons de calmer la
situation
cela étant ce n'est pas le fond du
problème le fond du problème ce que
véritablement la demande de la russie
pour sortir de cette situation de crise
qui ne concerne pas que l'ukraine ait de
bonnes bases mais qui concerne
l'ensemble du dispositif de sécurité
européen ce serait que l'otan c'est que
le temps revienne à ses frontières de
1997 c'est à dire qu'on revienne à une
situation de calme diplomatique de
sécurité pour le pour tout le monde pour
tout le monde et que la russie s'engage
bien évidemment assurer la sécurité de
ses voisins immédiats notamment les pays
bas et la pologne qui étaient là mais
c'est la solution c'est la seule
solution de paix qui peut se dessiner
dans les mois qui viennent et je pense
que nous allons et venir d'une manière
ou d'une autre car la russie aujourd'hui
a prouvé qu'elle avait les moyens de sa
politique vous êtes d'accord parce que
la deuxième solution n'est pas une
solution pour une raison simple c'est
que ce n'est pas l'otan qui décide mais
ce sont les pays qui décident librement
de rejoindre l'otan ou l'union
européenne et les pays faut le rappeler
quand même qu'ils ont été occupées par
l'union soviétique depuis la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale ont un très
mauvais souvenir de la présence des
forces russes ou soviétiques de l'époque
pardon et que ce souvenir est toujours
persistant dans ces pays
et qu'aujourd'hui ces pays ont pris
librement le choix de rejoindre l'otan
on va pas les faire revenir en arrière
là dessus en revanche il ya des
dispositifs physiques militaires qui
peuvent ne pas être présent aux
frontières qui peuvent ne pas allumer
des flammèches de conflits ça c'est un
autre sujet mais aujourd'hui demander
aux pays qui ont librement choisi de
rejoindre le temps de quitter le temps à
mon avis c'est un homme starter comme on
dit c'était pas sortir de l'otan
s'étaient d'au moins de démilitariser
ces zones et notamment en supprimant les
systèmes de missiles qui sont
aujourd'hui donc des systèmes qui
permettent d'atteindre moscou saint
pétersbourg sans aucune restriction
c'est là la grande crainte des bus et on
peut la comprendre ça a été la
proposition qui a fuité dans dans le
journal espagnol d'il ya quelques jours
dans laquelle les américains ont dit
écoutez pas de problème vous allez venir
vérifier qu'il n'ya pas de site domicile
et nous nous allons vérifier de votre
côté qui a pas deux sites de missiles
c'est ce que j'appelle les mesures de
confiance qui existait il ya encore
vingt ans et qui ont été balayés par
l'oubli par la mauvaise volonté
considération aussi parfois de de la
revue s'il ya eu
dans la bouche de certains dirigeants
occidentaux d'ailleurs lui c'est ce qu'a
dit le président macron ce que vous avez
fait passer tout à l'heure qui est très
très juste il faut prendre en compte
l'histoire ancienne bien sûr avec en
particulier l'ukraine mais aussi
l'histoire depuis les années 2000
globalement et que dont poutine à la
mémoire puisque ça fait 21 ans qu'il est
au pouvoir donc il a bien cette mémoire
la toul et les dirigeants européens ne
l'ont pas forcément ils ont une durée un
peu plus courte et donc il faut que tout
ceci plus soit pris en compte bien sûr
on va aller voir du côté de moscou à ce
qu'on pense justement les français sur
place olivier burri lot
justement quel est le sentiment des
français que vous croisez avec lesquels
vous avez pu échanger ces derniers jours
est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup d'attentes pour
cette rencontre mâcon poutine
aujourd'hui
oui bonsoir à tous bien sûr ici on a un
seul souci c'est de s'assurer que
dialogue reprend même si c'est pas un
dialogue bilatéral franco-russe c'est un
dialogue européen avec peut-être plus de
moyens plus de poids mais le plus
important c'est qu'heuliez du dialogue
on parle de mesures de confiance on
vient de parler de ça mais enfin il faut
pas oublier que les états unis sont
sortis du traité openskies récemment ça
c'est clairement un mauvais signal donc
en fait on avait des outils visiblement
il ya eu de la tension il est clair
aussi que la débâcle américaine en
afghanistan a tout déstabilisé
maintenant on assiste à un redéploiement
des troupes en europe bien évidemment la
situation en ukraine et très
conflictuelle donc tout ce qu'il peut
aller dans le sens du dialogue est une
bonne chose et on se réjouit de cette
visite bien sûr on ne sait pas ce qui va
en sortir il faut attendre demain
également
l'agenda du président qu'il s'est lui
même fixée pour pouvoir être candidat
aux présidentielles c'est à savoir
résoudre l'ukraine et éventuellement
locaux vides et un agenda très ambitieux
mais c'est positif et nous on laquelle
comme tel par contre ce que je vais vous
dire c'est que au niveau des russes du
quotidien on ne sent pas d'inquiétude
ils sont bien évidemment certains au
niveau militaire la force et de leur
côté évidemment ils ne veulent pas de
guerre ils le disent tous mais on
constate il faut quand même bien voir
que ils ont massé des troupes au sol il
faut pas oublier qu'en syrie ils ont
gagné ils ont sauvé le régime par des
troupes au sol et l'otan évidemment en
face ne peut pas aligner cent mille
hommes voilà donc espérons que tout ceci
va
revenir vers un dialogue constructif et
c'est notre souhait le plus cher un club
danse maison justement c'est intéressant
ce que nous dit parce que rien sauvagère
qui le prouvent 53 % des russes qui
jugent improbable ou exclu l'hypothèse
d'une guerre avec leurs voisins il ya
plus d'inquiétude du côté curieusement
européen on parle parfois même des
d'hystérie du côté américain
c'est ce qui lui même qui le disaient
vous êtes justement d'accord
écoutez moi je suis professionnellement
optimiste parce que lorsque il n'y a
plus de place sur la diplomatie pardon
mon général nous laissons la place aux
militaires par conséquent je pense que
la diplomatie est en oeuvre qu'elle est
complexe elle est très diversifiée comme
je l'étais tout à l'heure par divers
canaux en fonction des compétences des
uns et des autres et je crois que tout
ça devrait converger en effet vers des
résultats mais ça prendra du temps bien
entendu ça sera pas demain matin ça va
prendre un certain temps et pendant que
ces négociations ont lieu eh bien on ne
sait pas la guerre donc je crois que
c'est ça l'objectif recherché par macron
en concertation d'ailleurs avec avec
tous ses partenaires européens et si on
pouvait dans les prochaines semaines et
dans les prochains mois progresser sur
la la sphère du dombass ce serait un
très bon signe un très bon signal bien
entendu mais comme on l'a dit tout à
l'heure sur votre plateau l'ukraine
n'est qu'une partie du sujet le sujet
c'est ce que demande la lumière poutine
pour
ce qu'ils estiment devoir être là la
sécurité de la russie mais ça c'est une
négociation qui est largement entre lui
et les américains puisque en effet
il ne veut pas que des systèmes d'armes
soient stationnés dans des pays qui ont
rejoint l'otan ou qui n'ont pas rejoint
l'otan mais qui sont qui ont une
frontière commune avec la russie et ça
c'est une négociation qui peut
parfaitement se dérouler entre entre
heures entre moscou et washington
donc moi je pense qu'il est possible
d'arriver à une solution ça ne sera pas
ça ne sera pas très simple mais il faut
abandonner toutes les questions de
principe il faut
regarder chaque problème suivant ses
mérites propres et lui trouver une
solution une solution par la négociation
bien sûr je pense que c'est
techniquement possible
donc moi ce soir je suis plutôt
optimiste sinon je ne vois pas pourquoi
monsieur poutine aurait reçu monsieur
macron pourquoi la discussion a duré
aussi longtemps ni pourquoi monsieur
bouteilles auraient accepté
que la négociation en format normandie
reprennent alors qu'elle était gelé
depuis maintenant deux ans donc il ya
des signes qui indiquent que de part et
d'autre la volonté de bouger et de
trouver des solutions j'ajoute que oui
dans les pardons dangereux leurs forces
à l'austérité évoqué telle tâche lourde
à mettre au panier parce que on a parlé
de sommet avec baden de ce mec l'otan et
il manque un sommet c'est le fameux
sommet que monsieur macro et madame
merkel vous avons proposé à leurs
partenaires sans succès en juin dernier
un sommet entre la russie l'union
européenne ont donné moins que
blanchemaison gc distribuer la parole
sur ce plateau aussi c'est vrai que
c'est ça ça a été très commenté le fait
qu emmanuel macron viennent tout seuls
n'y aurait pas eu plus de poids de venir
avec olaf scholz qui est lui allé voir
joe biden il fallait arriver alors enfin
oui sauf que le chancelier allemand
vient d'arriver qu'il est probablement
aller régler quelques problèmes germano
américain en particulier les problèmes
de gaz directement à washington et que
comme je le disais tout à l'heure le
président macron a pris le soin
d'appeler individuellement tous les
européens pour avoir leur point de vue
et autour d'une table et 27 européens
devraient probablement pas eu la même
position comme le dit hier basterds
blanchemaison ils ont refusé le dialogue
pour l'instant il ya dans le rapport de
force il ya un point qu'on ne souligne
pas là c'est le problème de le temps
après ça a été soulignée à moscou après
la catastrophique opérations de kaboul
les américains ont besoin de réunifier
le temps et cette espèce de de montée en
gamme aujourd'hui par les américains et
les phares et balises en particulier sur
la menace qui n'est même pas reconnue
par le gouvernement ukrainien a lui-même
a pour objet de réunir tous les pays de
l'otan soul elle des américains mais ça
ça c'est un facteur qu'il faut avoir vu
et je pense que c'est un peu le piège
dans lequel est tombé monsieur brutin
paradoxalement monsieur poutine
ressuscitent le temps parce que han
nommé montant en gamme lui même il a
revivifiée les réflexes des européens
qui sont point de point de salut hors
des états unis et donc je pense que la
manoeuvre du président macron
aujourd'hui est de revenir à la
diplomatie par le biais du
dialogue établi le format la normandie
et de pouvoir enfin discuter politique
et non pas ce rapport de force
que ce côté général est juste sur la
première partie en revanche je considère
qu'on a la position de l'europe
aujourd'hui n'est pas crédible elle
n'est pas crédit parce que politiquement
l'europe ne parle pas d'une seule voix
c'est une honte on l'a vu c'est un conte
un contexte totalement hétérodoxes qui
n'est absolument pas unifié on a vu
récemment le président croate affirmé
qu'il refuserait de suivre le temps bien
qu'ils soient membres de l'otan en cas
de conflit entre la russie et l'ukraine
dont l'europe n'a pas de poids politique
et je pense que plus encore que cela le
plus important noté me semble-t-il c'est
que l'otan a perdu la suprématie
militaire ça c'est un point qui n'est
pas souligné hélas dans les médias
occidentaux mais il y a depuis au moins
2013 au moins depuis depuis 2013 et avec
une redondance en 2018 la preuve je dis
bien la preuve absolue que ni les états
unis ni l'otan ne maîtrisent les armes
du futur
c'est à dire que la russie aujourd'hui à
apporter des preuves qu'elle était
largement en avance sur l'occident et
que désormais l'otan n'étaient plus en
mesure d'imposer sa force et sa
domination et je pense c'est une chance
historique pour l'europe de sortir enfin
de sortir enfin de la domination des
états unis est d'essayer de retrouver en
tout cas pour la france de retrouver
cette position d'équilibré qui a
toujours été la sienne lorsqu'elle avait
une certaine souveraineté et qu'elle a
hélas perdu depuis qu'elle s'est mise à
la remorque de l'union européenne et de
l'otan en particulier mais raté français
à moscou y pense la même chose qui est
manuel le roi en substance en gros c'est
une occasion pour pour l'europe de
s'émanciper des des états unis
oui tout à fait simplement c'est vrai
que peut constater que malheureusement
pour le côté français on a il veut en
toute fin de mandat du président macron
en plus dans une campagne présidentielle
qui commence où il ne se déclare pas
candidat donc tout ça ce sont des
mauvais points je dirais mais bien sûr
on continue à penser qu' il faut que la
france retrouve de la souveraineté je
veux dire c'était évident on ne peut pas
être respectée si on se respecte pas soi
même voilà donc ça c'est très clair
rappelant que la france soit un moteur
de l'europe ce n'est pas une surprise et
je pense que la crise actuelle est
l'illustration grâce à la volonté du
président macron de d'être un moteur il
vient en tant que président français
mais en essayant de changer la position
européenne
rome ne s'est pas fait en un jour et
réunir 27 pays ça l'est pas et
spécialement surtout avec des histoires
différentes je rappelle je rappelle le
traumatisme de l'occupation soviétique
faut pas l'oublier quand vous allez dans
les pays baltes comme tel et en pologne
je vais vous dire que vous dites vous
êtes bien gentil les français mais vous
vous n'avez pas connu ça nous on l'a
connu et donc voilà il ya un moment où
si la russie ne doit pas jouer le rôle
qu'a joué l'union soviétique et faut
faire oublier un peu cette partie de
l'histoire aussi merci à tous les trois
en tout cas nous avons apporté votre
point de vue votre décryptage olivier
burnotte que je pense maison général
trinquant et emmanuel leroy sur ce
plateau merci à tous et merci